les vignes de la famille gendrier depuis
quelques heures
on s'active déjà dans les parcelles du
domaine
c'est tôt en saison mais en fait on
avait déjà une belle maturité un des
sucres avec beaucoup de secrets aussi
une faible acidité donc on trouve que
l'équilibré parfait maintenant et on a
décidé de commencer ce matin sur le
secteur et de manière générale dans la
vallée du cher
un peu partout les vignerons sont à pied
d'oeuvre
sécateur en main il arpente les
vignobles
ici on récolte du chardonnay du
sauvignon deux cépages pour réaliser un
cheverny blanc et les gracques semble
très correct comment est il le raisin la
longue une superbe maturité voyez des
raisins très doré gorgés de sucre avec
un bel équilibre sucre acidité chez les
gendrier en est vigneron depuis sept
générations
alexandre vendanges avec ses parents
depuis quatre ans selon le jeune homme
le cru 2015 s'annonce très prometteur ça
se présente comme un cru magnifique
étant donné que là comme vous pouvez le
voir là l'état sanitaire est superbe et
c'est relativement précoce mais on nous
annonce un superbe temps donc les
raisins sont mûrs
actuellement on nous annonce 10 à 15
jours de temps quasiment sans pluie donc
on a vraiment le temps pour travailler
tranquillement et rentrer la vendange
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
dans la journée environ un demi hectare
ainsi été vendangés à la main dans les
jours à venir
le travail va s'intensifier avec
l'arrivée des machines et d'autres
saisonniers pour vendanger aussi le
pinot noir